hello believe nation welcome to another
edition of the oven carmichael show-- i
am your host Evan Carmichael I'm super
excited to be here with you I have a
little bit of allergies today so pardon
the occasional sniffle that comes in
working on that the trees and the grass
are getting to me today but I'm super
excited for a show today I mean it's all
about helping you grow your business
helping you turn that idea that you have
into something meaningful something
impactful something you can make a lot
of money with to today I'm going to be
talking about how to get started as a
public speaker what holds a lot of
entrepreneurs back I have a special
guest john oda who's a business growth
x-pro who's going to come on and share
his wisdom and also talking about
perfectionism does it hold you back from
being the entrepreneur that you could be
so let's get into it so I got a question
from robert de mano who's one of my
viewers and he said can you provide me
with some tips and resources that helped
you get started when becoming a public
or motivational speaker super important
topic and for me it was never my plan to
be a public speaker I was an
entrepreneur I had some success i sold
my first business when i was 22 and as a
result i got asked to do a lot of
speaking and so that that kind of came
naturally kind of just fell into it but
if that was my goal if i wanted to be a
public speaker and I'm starting from
scratch that i'm going to give you three
tips that i think will help you the
first is you gotta practice you got to
practice practice practice you got to do
as many speaking engagements as you can
because there's so much competition
there's so many people who want to be
public speakers right now that it's
getting harder and harder and harder to
stand out and the people who are the
best who have the best message who
deliver it in a fantastic way those are
the people who stand out and get the
better gigs and so you have to get
better you gotta practice right it's not
enough just doing a few speeches every
now and then you got to be dedicated to
this crap and so I would practice on my
own I would pass in front of the mirror
I would practice in front of my friends
if possible I would practice at any
possible speaking engagement do it for
free volunteer you know do it for
nonprofits do it for school groups
whatever it is just to get better right
you have to get better and that's
not going to come if you're only
speaking once a month you gotta practice
practice practice second thing I get
onto YouTube for anybody for any
entrepreneur who has a visual product or
service something that I can see
something that when you demonstrate it
live it makes me want to take action
then you got to be on YouTube and I
think a fantastic way to do that is is
to show you the you know show show your
audience how you present how you speak
put that in there uh and and do it
frequently again you have to practice so
you know I'm at an agency as an example
and the agency that I that I'm with they
train people to be better thought
leaders they put people on to radio
shows and get them speaking gigs and
when I first started he said I was the
worst her head I was the worst at
delivery has the worst of my
presentations and I almost didn't get
into the agency and then three months
later I became the best practice on
YouTube became one of the best at the
agency and it wasn't because I was great
it wasn't because I had any fantastic
natural skill because I worked really
hard at it right most of the people at
the agency struggle to get one video up
per week if you're really dedicated to
this if you want to get better at this
you want to be a better speaker you have
to be able to do more than one video per
week how I got really good was I did two
videos per day every single day on my
youtube channel there are two new videos
coming out and that's how I got better I
practice I practice I practice and when
people couldn't find time for one video
a week i was doing two videos a day this
is important right if this is an
important goal of yours if you want to
get to that next step then you've gotta
practice and put in the time the other
thing that i found is a lot of my new
speaking gigs come from my youtube
channel people who are searching for
entrepreneurship people who are
searching in your case for motivation
then they would be searching on YouTube
and they could come across your channel
and there's a high likelihood that thing
I want to connect with you potentially
hire you and move forward so I practice
get on youtube and then model success
study great speakers people like Les
Brown Tony Robbins whoever does that you
look up to study them look at them you
know look break down their speeches and
how they tell stories and surround
yourself with them so that
you can apply those lessons to your
speaking career all right good luck
robert i want to get to the calls i have
Carol on the line Carol where are you
from and how can I help hi i'm in
charlotte north carolina how are you I'm
great are you in columbus all great
advice so far i guess my question is
this what do you also think about live
streaming because sometimes i do youtube
videos i get it but sometimes i don't
always have the time and I'd rather just
do it like I don't take as much to you
as I can what would you think about that
what are you selling I am a business
consultant and I work with a lot of
high-growth high-level entrepreneurs
high-level CEOs who are looking to kind
of expand and get past the plateau in
their revenue and so sometimes i'm
always looking for different ways of
prospecting but youtube is wonderful and
i do a lot of it i do have so far about
maybe 137 videos and that's a little bit
for some lessons only done it for a year
but i prefer that's just my personal
preference to do live streaming but i
will admit it is its own heading to get
people to get on at the time that you're
available yeah so a couple thoughts for
you one i love live streaming i do it
once a week in my channel i have a live
stream coming up later this afternoon on
my channel i think it's a fantastic way
to engage with users who are live and
say oh I get a chance to talk to Carol
and ask my questions you know it's
really great engagement and they feel
really connected to you I would suggest
doing it on a schedule so that they know
it's like the first thursday of every
month or every every thursday at three
o'clock you can talk to Carol on her
live stream then you'll start building
up a following and an audience and it's
easier for people to start to remember
the downside about live streaming is
that yes the video is still available
later on on YouTube for people to
consume the numbers aren't as great as
if you have a polished edited video
because there's a lot of you know in a
half an hour livestream there's not all
fantastic content and there's you know
maybe technical issues and you scroll
through comments you notice that there's
a lot of there's a lot of things in a
live stream that don't lend itself well
to consumption after the live stream
even though we'll get some viewers but
if you're feeling like it's
more natural for you then the best thing
is to do you write like you'll have the
most success doing what you love and
where you feel most at home and so
that's live streaming then then I'd go
all in on it right and have the thursday
afternoon livestream chat with Carol
okay are using Google Hangouts to do it
no I also have done spreecast as in a
lot of spreecast I do Google Hangouts
but I sometimes don't like that the
actual platform people can't kind of
keep coming in and out so I've been
doing spreecast and at least the stream
is available afterwards they can watch
right after I've done as well as it also
goes to now to youtube so some of my
spree cats are now available and you too
so that's one of the reasons I kind of
like it god I think you people ask you
questions yes people can ask questions
they can actually post it on the side so
I can answer their questions as they're
typing the man and I also give people
the opportunity to kind of come on
screen with me so that we can share
screen and I can just do life coaching
right then in there so I can just do it
like five minute leaves a session so
they can really get the value instead of
you know typing in a question you know I
invite them to click on sharing a screen
and that helps but again you know the
Kabul into the conversion rates a little
but I say that it's hard to get people
to commit because i'm really only
available at a certain time to do
something live and a lot of people would
say that you know i'm not available at
end of class i'm going to be able to
bend and that's always its own issue
where people want to still ask questions
but it's after that time and so they
wanted to ask it live on the show but
they can't so you know a couple options
one is figuring out do you care right
like there's a there is there is a nice
cachet and the exclusivity of it only on
this time and it forces people to pay
more attention and there's the exclusive
element of it your other option is to
take a question or two that's from
somebody where you where you answered on
the show right like just leading off
this show I answer the question from
Robert who is one of my YouTube
subscribers who asked me a question I
answered it on radio show now we're
going to you who's live right so you can
mix it up if that's a format that works
well with your style I would look at
doing hangouts more because it helps
really build your YouTube community and
YouTube's the game right
want people subscribing to your YouTube
channel and tuning in every week at a
certain time the technology can be a
little clunky there are ways around it
but I think I think YouTube is probably
a better choice to live stream to the
google hangout platform because it's
done your YouTube subscribers asking you
the questions and you're building your
audience okay definitely well thank you
cool well thank you for calling in good
luck with the the casting so for
everybody listening if you're looking at
getting started you try to do a
screencast I was talking to being a
public speaker having a live session on
YouTube is a fantastic way to go you
have an audience you have people asking
you questions you are able to engage
with them doing it live is is a great
way to do it I still have a mix i
finally get more long-term success from
having edited polish videos and then I
mix in the live stuff but again do you
do do the thing that makes you excited
makes you come alive that fits naturally
with your talents and skills and you'll
see that you start to rise up and
leverage it and start to get some
traction to help you grow your business
today we're talking about strategies and
ideas to grow your business I recent got
asked a question from one of my viewers
Phoenix wrote in the say you know what
holds me back my friends they have
talent in areas that I lack talent in
and I can't create things at the rate
that they do and I want to move forward
this is a this is a super important
topic okay first of all I think you
should be grateful okay just like let's
step outside of your world for a moment
be grateful because your product of your
environment most people don't have
people to push them a lot of the
entrepreneurs I know don't have people
in their network who are doing things
that are better than them and they're
pushing them to be better right there's
the expression that you are the result
of the five people in your life right
the closest five friends that you have
and that's true right you are a product
of your environment and if you have
friends who are doing things that are
better than you that you aspire to be
that's good because they're going to
pull you along that journey where if
your friends are all doing simple boring
mediocre things and hate their lives
that's bad because you're going to get
sucked down into that negative vibe and
energy so I would just take as a first
step take a step back and realize that
you are really you're really
fortunate you should be grateful for
having people who push you to be better
okay the second thing is don't try to be
them you know if you're comparing
yourself to other people that could be a
great goal like I want to be able to
compete at this level I wanna be able to
produce this kind of quality I don't
know what kind of product or service
you're making but at the end that they
for you to have true success is going to
be from you being you and stop trying to
be them right you can't compete at being
them you can't beat them at being them
instead you want to be the best version
of yourself and that mean mean taking a
few steps back to really explore
yourself and figure out what you could
be the best in the world that to then
move forward and explode and really
leverage so that would be my advice
right it's great to have these friends
who are pushing to be better but don't
try to be like them don't just compare
on what they're better at because that's
not you focus on what you're really good
at focus on your strengths and create
something amazing I have Jason on the
line Jason where are you from and how
can I help hey we're down here in Spring
Hill Florida all right how can I help
Jason say we we've been down here for a
few months got a house with a pool just
got married she's significantly younger
than I am you know she has opinions I
have life experiences that's our first
problem okay yeah now we have now we're
starting a business together and I'm
thinking okay this is gonna be great you
know she'll do the things that she's
good at all to the things I'm good at
all and boy just not working out that
way I mean she still is not picking up
that it's about money it's about getting
fired up it's about getting excited and
and I'm try I can't motivate her I mean
we can be broke but that's still not
motivating her I don't get it you know
it's hard beating partnerships in
general let alone partnerships with your
life partner and you have to decide you
know how obviously important that
relationship is to you and the
relationship should come before the
business and it honestly may mean one of
you exiting the company and just
supporting the other person and not
working together because that could be
detrimental to your marriage well I'm
certainly reconsidering hopefully you
know right now luckily we're still early
in the game here where I could
say hey you just do this thing you over
here what a way way over here and I'll
do all this over here no hard feelings
spit on her hand give each other a
handshake and a hug and kind of be on
our way that's where I'm at yeah and you
know you can't change people right you
could try to change people but you can't
change people like if she's not
motivated by you being broke I'm really
needing money and you are and that's
causing conflict in the business you're
not gonna you're not going to change her
right you're not going to suddenly make
her now motivated by money it's not
going to work so you know if you guys
have a happy marriage and happy life
outside of the company then that's
probably the best way to handle it is to
split split the business like you're off
doing a business if that's your passion
she's off doing something that she's
super excited about because it's not
worth the headache and the nightmares
and just the stress if you're not
getting along inside the company well
yeah that's a whole nother you know dr.
Phil episode right there whether I'm not
dr. Phil if she says she's not going to
get up and get fired up and you know
she's still waking up at noon every day
I mean what is it going to take to light
a fire under a but you know she's gonna
do something she's excited by maybe it's
not the business well I'm just thinking
it's just heard her you know she's in
her early mid 20s I'm in my late 30s you
know so it's a generational thing
perhaps of the entitlement again and
that's a whole nother issue a whole
nother topic did talk about there has
been times I guarantee where she's been
excited when she's been motivated where
she's you know woken up early and been
excited to go do something it's just not
this business and she's got a fine and
it may be part of her self discovery and
journey but she's got to find something
that she gets excited to buy that makes
her come alive and makes her want to
explore and put effort into something
and for you that could be your business
and other things that you're working on
it for her it's something different
maybe she hasn't figured it out yet it's
not worth the stress and headache to try
to force her into the business if you're
not if you guys aren't getting along in
it and i would i would have a
conversation with her to say that you
really value her you value your
relationship you want you know you guys
as a couple to work out and and you
don't see a way to do that and be in
business league at the same time instead
of saying okay yo you go on your way
i'll do this i'll do my thing you do
your thing she
some compassion right like be honest and
that you you care about your
relationship you want both you to be
happy and it's probably best to move on
well I'm not going to give up again I
mean she and I will have a few more
talks before we officially go live with
the website and all the fancy jazz right
now we we just been developing
prototypes and getting a few things
taken care of you know preliminary
things haven't officially launched
anything until you know late next week
or so so you know I'm gonna give myself
a a week deadline or so you know maybe
she'll see the big picture I don't know
good luck you know again it's hard to
change people but but you know remember
the cheese your wife first and business
partner second yeah yeah that's what I
keep on thinking all right good luck
Jason all right hey thank you no problem
and for everybody listen to as business
partners man I mean I've been down that
road it's hard having business partner
you spend more time with your business
partner than you do with your husband or
wife I mean it's it's intense and you
have to make sure you guys get along and
you're not going to agree on everything
but you have to have the same values you
have to want the same thing you have to
have the same kind of drive and ambition
motivation if you don't and it's not
going to work out and if you are in a
relationship with your significant other
it's a whole new ball game adds tons of
complexity and you have to make sure
that you understand that you guys are
husband and wife first or you know
boyfriend and girlfriend first and you
value that relationship more than the
business and put each other first and
have that as a priority so I feel I feel
you guys everybody who's going through
those problems today we're talking about
how to grow your business and I'm really
excited to have a special guest on with
me dr. John Oda who is a business growth
and coach expert welcome to the program
thank you so much Evan long time man huh
and how's things going for you man
things are amazing and it's great to
have you on the show I think is the
first time you get on the radio show it
is definite all right let's get into it
you know you're the growth expert so
when someone is trying to grow a company
what do you think is the first thing
that they need to work on we don't then
the very first and of that people should
work out as your mindset
and the reason why they work on the
mindset is because we're going to have
problems and challenges and everything's
going to take place right if you don't
have the proper mindset the business is
not going to grow so I give you a great
example I was working with a couple of
businesses and the owner had a negative
mindset so I was like everything would
go wrong of him he if you get mad and
then he'd get in this tyrant state right
what I proud of you need to change your
emotions change your mindset get
positive and then when that takes place
that you know all of his all every last
one of his employees will follow him
also and the biggest and and and about
this mindset dictates everything that is
your whole success because you mind set
I love that how do you go about changing
your mindset if you have a negative one
well that's a couple times the very
first thing that you can do you can read
this great book that I tell everybody is
to read and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill
right great but great but the book is
phenomenal it's a great I was written
back in the 40s and maybe in the 30s
phenomenal book right and that that is
the first the second ten about is you
have to change your environment meaning
that you have to hang out with people
who are like-minded positive upbeat
exciting that's another way I've how to
change your mindset but then again
though the third way is you just ask
yourself limit to me if I have this
mindset who's going to follow me and and
and then again though being a business
owner you have to be like the Pied Piper
you have to have you have to have you
have to have your employees follow you
lead you and then ash and then and then
plus at once that takes place your whole
business will actually succeed I love it
and I'm feeling the energy and the
excitement in your voice too man i love
it now you like to talk about
educational marketing as well can you
can you talk about what that is and why
it's so important exactly so so for all
the lives right we've been learning
learning
running running running from
kindergarten to you know it's a
preschool to first grade all the way up
to right and what I found out a lot of
businesses right they don't even educate
people what they do is they try to sell
people right my concept in businesses
you want to become the expert now think
about this you can go to a Tony Robbins
can go to a chat homes excuse me delayed
care homes right and what and then like
them and for number one or what they did
was they educated you they became the
expert and think about this people
businesses they pay for the expert do
you like experts can charge 15 20
thousand dollars and then lack of them
you will pay for it I give you a great
example I used to live in the state of
Oregon years ago and I used to have a
house with these crazy skylights and I
caught up three people caught up to
people from the state of Oregon Portland
one person from Seattle so the two
people from Portland came in there they
gave me the price tag the third person
came like maybe like maybe two days
later he came in there and he says you
know how much is the house and I told he
says how much do you think you were
fears us another not maybe a couple
hundred thousand he said you know what
though if you don't clean these
skylights out the right way it can write
on your roof right in your whole house
and then you know your house won't be
worth that much money Kevin he scared
the crap out of me uh uh huh hmm maybe
maybe this guy is right now thank you
buddy this guy trashed at forty percent
more so what I did was I said you know
wifey up so you know what should we do
and of course my wife said it go with
the cheap one and i said but how about
if they don't know how to clean the
skylights the right way and of course
what i did was i chose the 10 educated
me people pay for the expert and that's
why all of your marketing from your
website to your post it should be
educational because the biggest goal is
you want so someone to so if we can say
this is the expert I want to use them
and nobody want to be sold so I give you
another example i went to a car
dealership to get a car and I was
looking at this car and beautiful car in
and I was going to walk out because you
know this guy tell me oh man that's a
great car all the girls are like you
know Mike
and Mary doesn't make a difference to
girls like me or not right and i'll go
ahead and to leave right and then the
older guy came up to me sick excuse me
why are you leaving i said is not for me
he said so what do you think the safest
car is and i said it mobile he said oh
no no no mercedes is the safest car and
he showed me these brochures and showing
me about all these airbags now the
airbag that they had and how everything
else what I walked outside with Mercedes
right because the guy educated me and
that's why but I say education is the
key you must and you must educate your
audience I love it and I love how you
use an example from a service provider
and then also somebody selling a product
ready selling cars a lot of people think
the X were just as oh I'm a consultant
you know I'm a speaker but here like hey
he's selling cars that's a real tangible
product and you can still sell by being
the expert exactly i mean and and then
you know though what people gotta
understand not just think about this all
through high school all q college all
through grade school we learn and learn
and learn now you need to think about
your ideal client and most of times are
ideal client that you're going to go get
our mercedes you're going to be educated
you're going to be this or that right
but think about it you at least have a
high school education and people always
want to learn I mean we have internet
right now the internet have immediately
I don't like Google anything in there it
can tell me every day why don't we
market the exact same way now here to go
once you people mark it that way they
become the expert people go yeah you
know let me go to John because he
looking more like John would teach me
something you a job won't sell me but he
would teach me something investigate
what do you think so for somebody who's
may be doing the total opposite of that
you haven't done any education marching
and they're just the hard selling you
know entrepreneur what's the what's the
easy way to start what's an easy way to
test this like what's my first step to
dive into educational marketing the
first way or what i would do is so for
example go for us
in your industry go for a more of like
educational marketing when I teach it to
my clients we go for more of pain points
maybe the three devastated mistakes p
you know um people make when doing x y&z
because think about it people are going
to get off the dime for pain right so if
it's painful if they're going to lose
anything they'll go for it if you say
you know you need the service because
it's going to make you feel great and
you'll be doing great you like yeah I
needed maybe one day right doing it this
way is it's going to be this is going to
be urgency you're going to want it right
now medical man guys this is me that's
not me I could lose this I could lose
that so without first end of that I
would do is to a step again another
example I had a doctor in Australia does
work among unused the chiropractor and
he said it in his first statement and
you 1,900 people with to be 50 I said
okay and then he said in 2001 people
live to be 81 and I said Dan wow I
didn't know that and he caught me wow
that's a good one right because he
educated me first right and then of
course was then and of course have any
would incite his whole concept of
educating a person and the great thing
about education of marketing he did not
talk and about his service or else's
product he educated you right and then
and then plus it a one-seat as you can
into on the pain points what's going to
take place approaches have listened to
me no one have told me this except for
you so you must be the expert I love it
dr. John Oda everybody where can we
learn more about you for people who are
curious want to improve their mindset
and learn about educational marketing
and grow their business fabrikam like a
liquid reach me on my website which is
wwan Oda com sowww drjays.com I love a
man thanks for joining in and for
everybody who's listening no educational
marketing is something I'm a strong
believer in and in dr. John Oda wrote a
great article on mice
like that was the eight devastating
business growth mistakes all businesses
make got a lot of traction got a little
advice you know got a lot of people
commenting on it and it led to a lot of
people learning about my website about
him as well and so try to be the expert
whether you're selling a product whether
you're selling a service show that you
are knowledgeable and I really believe
in that statement instead of just trying
to hard sell somebody instead of just
trying to you know put their pain points
in there also try to show that you know
what you're talking about and that you
care about their best interest I got a
question about perfectionism from noob
for life 91 saying Evan I was warned if
you can share your opinions with us on
perfectionism so there's good and bad
sides of this and I used to be a lot
more of a perfectionist I am now the
good side is it means you care right
being a perfectionist means you care
means you don't release garbage products
means you're creating things that people
will use and are meaningful to their
lives the bad side is that it's never
done right you're striving for something
that is unattainable it can never be
perfect there's always something to add
there's always always always something
to add pneus never finished whether
you're writing a book whether you're
creating the song whether you're making
shoes whether you're writing code for
software it's never done there's always
something you could tweak and what that
does is holds products back it means you
never release it right and so you gotta
you gotta make sure you don't go that
far with it it also means that often
you're creating a vacuum you're creating
things without getting feedback from
your customers and you need that
feedback to improve it right you can't
just create the best product ever for
your customer sitting in your apartment
you gotta you gotta be able to get their
feedback put it into the product
development make it something that's
even better for them and so the acid
test that I would use if you are
perfectionist is don't make it perfect
don't hold on to the release until it's
perfect it's never going to get there
instead use the acid test of are you
proud of it are you proud of what you
create is not perfect yet but are you
proud of it if you are then release it
because if you're a perfectionist you
have such high standards that if you're
proud of it chances are most people are
going to love it it's beyond the
expectations of most of the people who
you're going to be selling to then
release it improve it release version to
version 3 version 4 keep making it
better and better
better and release when you're proud all
right I have time for one last caller I
have summer on the line summer where are
you from and how can I help hi I'm from
Indianapolis Indiana and I was wanting
to know some good brain being techniques
excuse for my business I'm really good
marketing and branding to get my
business name out there I love what do
you do I own my own clothing store okay
and what's different about your Chloe
well it's trendy plus size women's
clothes and the stuff that you can wear
you know to the club or from work or I
mean I just have everything in my store
woman can walk in and walk out with
everything she will need for the weekend
are you plus size yourself yes I am I
love it um I think you need to tell the
story of why you started this store and
and who it's for and that you know if
it's making plus size women feel
comfortable feel acceptable feeling
confident if that's why you start at the
store I mean I'm putting words in your
mouth but that's something that can get
people excited right now you're not just
a clothing store your clothes and sort
it stands for something your clone sorta
has meaning behind it and you didn't
just start the store because it oh hey
maybe I'll start a business right I'm
sure you had an intention of purpose
behind starting this and that's what
needs to get out so people can tell your
story okay okay that makes sense so why
did you start your store what do you
what is your what does summer stand for
as a human being and how are you putting
that into your business well i started
my store because no one in our area was
selling the trendy plus size and i
really don't like to use the word plus
i'ma say curvy fashions and everything
either was something that your
grandmother would wear but it was really
nothing to appeal to us younger curvy
girls so that's what made me start the
store in those that give women
confidence so in my clothing is much
difference not as expensive as the most
decent plus size clothes clothing are I
mean what I fell is something when women
walk in they do have confidence they
look really good when they read they
take pictures in my store post a
facebook so i just want more people i
just want to reach more people in the
Indiana or Indianapolis area to be able
to draw them into my store I love it you
and if you don't like the word
plus-sized don't use it right like come
up if it's curvy women then it's curvy
right that's that's part of the that's
part of the atmosphere is buying from
your company right so you're giving
curvy women confidence that's the image
that you want to project right and and
now that's something that is way more
meaningful than okay I'm gonna go look
you know for cooling store and you're
one of 30 that I'm going to go check out
right I'm going to go online and look at
some clothes on Amazon or whatever right
now now you when I it comes from
everything about your store like you
have an advantage nice a retail location
you know do I walk in feeling confident
right like dude do I see other curvy
women pictures on the wall with quotes
that make me feel like I should feel
confident being a curvy woman just
walking into your store where most of my
life if I'm walking around and I'm a
curvy woman I might feel a lack of
confidence i might feel people are
judging me people are looking at me
people are making fun of me that might
be my like daily experience in you know
my life with friends and going to work
and that all kind of disappears when i
go to your store because i feel
confident and happy and accepted by
walking just walking into your store
dealing with you or if you have staff
looking at the clothes like that's the
atmosphere that you want and if you get
that happening then people will will
share it right and they'll come back way
more often and they'll tell their
friends and they'll bring their friends
along with them okay why you're even if
some ideas okay so we look at the
experience from from the outside of the
store to the inside of the store you
know companies do a great job of this or
our companies like Disney right when you
walk into disney you feel like you're
you're transported to a different world
right it's a magical new world that
celebrates happiness and dreams coming
true and kids and fun and so that should
be the same thing when I walk into your
store but instead giving me as a curvy
woman confidence in an acceptance and
ability to express myself and happiness
and I don't get that anywhere else you
know in Indiana this is the place to go
in Indiana
okay okay yeah that makes sense cool I
love it good luck if I'm driving by in
the end I'm gonna pop in okay awesome
please if all right thanks our thanks
for calling it and for everybody
listening you have tons of competition
right there's no way you're the only one
selling what you have and the people
you're going up against you have to make
it clear how you're different you have
to make it clear what you stand for what
makes you unique and that's what makes
you a brand that's what makes people
want to talk about you that's what
people will pay more for because they
want that experience beyond just buying
the clothing that wraps up another show
thank you guys so much for all of the
questions in the comments and the
attention i love it I feed off of it I
want to thank my producers again Brandon
and Josh you guys rock I'll be on again
next month until then continue to
believe continue to invest in your
business continue to work on your your
mindset and educational marketing and
the brain and all the stuff that we
talked about thank you guys so much I'll
see you soon